and uh and i can uh i can send copies of
that paper out if people are interested
thank you very much austin
uh so our next speaker is avi feller
from here's berkeley and
they'll tell us about extension's
resistance dragon post method
is this working
all right hi um good morning everyone um
i so first uh
it's really daunting to go after alice
and i don't have any
uh babies or other cute things in my
slides nor do i have any deep causal
reasoning um so this is going to be
pretty much the opposite end of the
causal difference spectrum so i think
apologies for the intellectual whiplash
there um this is i don't know about you
but this is my first in-person
conference
and i'm still
kind of getting used to it the whole
like presenting in a mask like figuring
out where to put my hands like wearing
pants
like all of that is stuff i'm still sort
of
uh you know leaning into a little bit so
uh apologies in advance if things a
little rusty but it has been really nice
to meet everyone uh particularly the uh
like the early career folks or i guess
i'm still early career so the earlier
career folks uh around here it's just
been uh it's so nice to be part of such
a vibrant uh and growing community so
it's been it's been great to meet folks
and so thank you to the organizers for
uh
for putting this on um so my name is avi
feller i am on faculty here at uc
berkeley i have a joint appointment in
the department of statistics in the
school of public policy so a lot of my
work is really at the interface
of those two things and it's um it's
really public policy questions that
uh give rise to this the topic of
today's talk which is around estimating
causal effects
with panel data using uh the focus on
policy interventions all right so before
i dive in uh this is joint work with my
now former phd student eli ben michael
and my senior colleague jesse rostein
who's a labor economist
and this is um this is a little bit
older work uh it's now actually
published in two papers one in jazz and
jssb but we have lots of ongoing
projects including with
some folks i see here like sophie hi
sophie um so please feedback very much
welcome and encouraged
all right so causal effects with panel
data and policy interventions so what do
i have in mind well by panel data i mean
something where i am
observing units repeatedly over time and
the you know
that's going to be annoying if that
keeps happening
um
uh where i observe units repeatedly over
time and the kind of units that i have
in mind are jurisdictions so typically
like a city a state or country and you
know i think unfortunately oh that's a
little small but we're all kind of very
familiar with this data structure by
staring at covid case counts right so we
observe covid case counts by country
um you know daily or weekly and then
some countries you know enact a masked
mandate or some countries uh connect a
major lock down and we all find
ourselves kind of staring at the world
in data numbers sort of saying like all
right
can we somehow intuit or tease out the
effect of these lockdowns
based on this repeated data structure
recognizing of course that countries
aren't randomly locking down i mean even
though it feels like that sometimes
right they're not randomly locking down
they're not randomly and asking mass
mandates so can we use that repeated
structure to kind of try to tease out
that effect
now don't worry i won't talk much about
cova today right most of my work
is on u.s domestic policy and so in the
u.s right we have our our 50 states our
50 laboratories of democracy and
in kind of any policy area you can think
of some states an act of policy and
others don't so for instance one project
that we've been working on recently is
on
a firearm reduction program that was an
act launched here in california in the
mid-2000s and the question is uh can we
look at say firearm-related homicide
rates by state over time and can we
look at those rates for california and
then for states that don't enact this
policy and can we use that to try to get
at this the effect of this major firearm
reduction program right and the answer
is you know maybe we can we're not
totally sure right it's a hard problem
um but this kind of structure shows up
everywhere
it i'm a policy guy but it it also shows
up in tech so we see a lot of this more
recently and
say google and uber
have
both have teams that work on these kinds
of panel data methods so you know uber
will roll out a new pricing scheme in a
given marketplace and they want to use
these kinds of ideas to see if they can
get that effect
all right so huge problem uh in lots of
areas
many many different ways of
approaching this
the framework i'm going to talk about
today
is known as the synthetic control method
right so originally proposed by um i
know we got a bunch of mit here folks
here originally proposed by alberto
avedy and colleagues in a series of
papers
the the key idea behind the synthetic
control method is actually quite simple
and elegant right we have a treated unit
like say the state of california and we
observe it repeatedly over time
and then we have a bunch of control
units or untreated units say the other
states
and we want to
the idea behind the method is to
re-weight the other states
and those to find a weighted average and
that weighted average is called the
synthetic control
such that the synthetic control looks
like
the treated unit prior to the
intervention
there are all sorts of uh variations on
the theme but that's the kind of core
idea and then to get the causal effect
you fast forward post-intervention and
compare the observed outcome for your
treated unit
to i should stand here sorry served
outcome for your treated unit
to the uh synthetic control
so this is an incredibly popular method
in the social sciences particularly in
things like policy evaluation here's a
plot you can't read it at all but this
is um
the use of synthetic control methods
over time in econ papers i can show you
similar plots for political science and
for policy analysis
right athene inbenz in a big review
called this arguably the most important
innovation in the policy evaluation
literature in the last 15 years
um keto jokes that this phrase is quoted
so often that will be on his tombstone
um but um you know it but inbenz in his
nobel lecture actually devoted a chunk
of time to talking about some time
controls so this is something that a lot
of people use
and i should say um this is something
that actually i a method i'd stayed
pretty far away from didn't really work
in panel data panel data is hard right
until i came here to berkeley into the
policy school
and my colleagues
routinely would come and ask me about
using synthetic control they'd say oh i
want to use it in this area i want to
use it in that area like why is it
working here why isn't it working there
and one theme that kept coming up
is this idea of excellent pre-treatment
fit
so
aberdeen colleagues in their papers are
very explicit to their credit that you
should really only use this approach if
you have quote excellent pre-treatment
fit so what do i mean by that well this
i'll i'll explain where these come from
in a few slides but this is the
difference between the treated unit and
the synthetic control
this is pre-intervention this is
post-intervention
and excellent pre-treatment fit
means that the treated unit and the
synthetic control
are right around zero here right that
difference is right around zero so we
see that the state of ohio has great
pre-treatment fit
we see that the state of new york does
not
so our weighted average of other states
does a really lousy job of capturing
what's going on in new york prior to the
intervention
and iowa is kind of somewhere in the
middle
right so you don't really know or am i
in the good am i in the good world or
the bad world do i proceed do i not like
how do i think about that
and so this really to me is is a major
hurdle with using this approach in
practice in a lot of seconds right at
least a lot of settings that i've seen
and
at least anecdotally this leads to a
real file drawer problem right
any policy researcher i've talked to has
done
some synthetic control analysis that
they
didn't move forward on because
they were more in this world than in
this world
and so what my co-authors and i do in a
series of papers is to try to think
about all right how can we
kind of adapt this method extend this
method um to make it more usable in
these different settings
and i'm a very simple man so i like to
use very simple ideas and uh the ideas
that we're using are from
the uh the causal and principle of tron
observational studies
so just two very simple ideas from that
world and all we're doing is taking them
and porting them over to the panel data
synthetic controls world and i should
say my ideas are very simple i'm looking
around the crowd and and seeing lots of
folks who are already
like taking these kinds of tools and
making them much much better so there's
more exciting stuff to come but for
today i want to focus on some of these
simple ideas
and the simple ideas the first one is to
say
in a setting where we have multiple
treated units
right so many states adopt over time and
we're interested in the average effect
among these units
we should try to do a good job of
balancing the average across the states
now this seems a little tautological but
as i'll show you in practice what a lot
of folks do is they'll estimate synth
separately for every state and then
average
and that can often lead to
doing a bad job of balancing the average
so we're just going to kind of shift the
optimization problem slightly to also
try to balance the average and we think
that's a reasonable thing to do
so that's our first simple change our
second is in settings where
we're just not getting good balance
with a weighting estimator
let's uh bring in an outcome model the
same way we would with doubly robust
estimation or the same way we would with
bias correction for matching right can
we use an outcome model to help soak up
any of the remaining variation
so those are kind of two simple ideas
that we've moved from here over to here
and take our specific methods leave them
fine but the point i i
what i do hope we take away
is
to me i think about synthetic controls
as a special case of this broader class
of problems known as balancing weights
problems
and
um that connection for me has been very
useful in trying to understand when i
think this method's gonna work well and
when it's not so depending on time and
interest i can talk about that briefly
at the end
all right
i think um
sorry about five past is that right
something like that
so okay cool um
so this is not a policy crowd i get that
but as a policy researcher i'm obligated
to at least spend a slide on my
application of interest so please bear
with me all right um so teachers unions
are very much in the news today right
they're kind of seen as a very powerful
political force but um
something i didn't really know until
recently there's actually a relatively
recent development in
the us so as recently as the 1950s
uh only about five percent of teachers
were in unions and that started to
change dramatically with what are known
as mandatory collective bargaining laws
so what these laws these laws are
enacted at the state level and they
essentially require
local
governments to recognize teachers units
so this makes these unions much more
powerful it
tends to dramatically increase union
membership it does a bunch of other
things too but that's the kind of
um
the the kind of key change and so
uh between the 50s and 80s 33 states you
can see them enacting here right enact
one of these mandatory collective
bargaining laws yep does this mean uh
the teachers if they want to form a
union they don't have to go to like the
nrv
they're they're like just automatically
recognized
what does it mean how is it different
from how i would for me if i'm not a
teacher yeah great question and it's a
much longer answer uh but because
teachers are public sector employees the
laws around
uh floods governing their unions are
different than the private sector unions
that you might see that are kind of a
typical nlrb style union membership
drive and so essentially what these
states did
it differs in different states but
largely prior to these laws
there was essentially a ban on teachers
unions as public sector employees they
were not they didn't have the right to
unionize
in the same way as a private sector
union would and these laws essentially
changed that they allowed these
they allowed teachers unions to form and
give them depending on the state gave
them lots of other powers as well does
that help yeah so should i think about
it as like
they were not allowed to unionize and
now they are or they think about it as
they're encouraged to unionize and it's
actually really easy for them to do so
or does that even
matter it doesn't really matter okay it
doesn't really matter um depending on
the state is liberal okay right some
states had more encouragement than
others so there's some slight variations
in the laws across
there's a lot more i'd uh point to lots
of great papers about it um
all right but
uh
sort of setting aside the mechanism just
a little bit right this did have the
upshot of dramatically increasing
membership so i went from about five
percent so just empirically right it
went from about five percent the fifties
to about eighty percent or sixty percent
in the 80s
and the question is what was the effect
of this on spending right or on other
education priorities and there was a
really there was a seminal paper in the
90s
arguing that this change
really increased uh education spending
right that this rising union membership
by a very large 12 percent
um some more recent papers have called
that into question so
i've said partly using new data using
new methods
actually we don't really believe this
kind of 12 percent increase as much um
and so what we do in our paper um
maybe maybe chris is the one who cares
about it in this room is we uh we
reassess this using these kind of newer
tools things like static controls and in
general we find kind of no meaningful
effect of these policy changes so that's
just the punch line from later on i know
you all care a little bit more about the
method
but
that's the that's where we're going with
this
all right
so let me
about 15 minutes in what i want to do
now there are a few different things
like um
i'm hoping to mention briefly
uh the first is i'm going to walk
through the kind of core of the
synthetic control approach and what you
would do in what people tend to do in
practice when you have multiple treated
units which is do this separately for
every state and then average uh then
i'll talk a little bit more about
um
what about states where you still have
lousy balance can you use bias
correction and other methods
to uh get better fit
and then i don't think i'll have time
but i'll briefly mention this connection
of balancing weights at the end
good and yes thanks to chris for
questions please other questions let me
know this is the whole like one of the
points of doing this in person is we can
actually engage like this
all right so to set the scene
let us look at the great state of ohio
this is uh
log per pupil student expenditures and
log constant dollars over time we see
spending goes up
and then in 1984
right ohio and acts one of these
mandatory collective bargaining laws
right and
we're causal influence folks so we want
to know what would have happened okay
let me
recenter everything so that the law of
passage is year zero
we want to know what would have happened
in ohio right in the absence of this
intervention would spend gone more would
have gone up less right we don't know
what's that what would counter factual
spending be
and already here you can see there's
some obvious things you could try
so you could for instance do what's
known as an interrupted time series you
could fit
a time series model here
extrapolate it forward and then compare
that extrapolation to ohio
it turns out to be kind of a lousy thing
to do here it's actually often a lousy
thing to do in policy settings but here
especially there are a lot of other
changes going on in the 80s across the
country on
uh affecting education policy and so we
wouldn't really believe that
extrapolation that doesn't take that
into account
all right so that's just if you have
ohio
we could for example
use instead the 17 states that don't
enact one of these policies
right so these are kind of pure control
states and we can compare ohio to say
you know the unweighted average of these
other states
and
this if you're uh an econ type you might
call this diff and diff
right and this will be a good idea if we
think that the gap between the red line
and this unweighted average is constant
over time
well if you look hard and you can do it
more formally you see that that's not
true here but it's kind of more narrow
here it's it's much wider here so you
don't really believe this
um
the so-called parallel trends assumption
like we don't think that would be
necessarily plausible here
all right so this is comparing ohio to
an unweighted average of other states
we can instead compare ohio to a
weighted average of other states
right and that's the synthetic control
approach so here's a sketch of the um
the optimization problem down here
and what we're doing is we have y here
is going to be our vector of lagged
outcomes we compare
the outcomes for ohio to this weighted
average
of other states
with weights gamma
and um the weights are going to be
chosen to minimize the squared imbalance
between ohio and the synthetic control
in this kind of canonical setting the
weights are going to be restricted to be
on the simplex so non-negative and sum
to one and just to make things nice and
kosher we're going to put a penalty on
the weights to make sure that we have a
unique solution
so we throw that in
and what do we see we see that
the
rather than
averaging over 17 states we're now
averaging only over seven
with most of the weight on things like
colorado and wyoming with a little bit
of utah thrown in for good measure right
things like that
and
we see here that actually this does a
pretty good job of tracking ohio over
time
so
it's often useful to look at this not on
the original scale but on the different
scale
so this is the difference between ohio
and synthetic ohio
and so we see prior to the intervention
this is kind of nice and happy around
zero
and then we would interpret anything
here
um
with some caveats as an estimate of the
causal effect
so remember i said there are 33 states
this is one of them
right so we do this in ohio
we could do this oh sorry quick notation
change let me call this this quantity
down here let me just call it
state balance for ohio
all right we can do this for ohio we can
do this for iowa we do this for new york
we can do this for all 33 treated states
separately
and this is just a convenient way of
writing the optimization problem
together it's
it breaks apart so this is 33 problems
together
all right and then for instance in the
average what we would do is we would
take the average
and it's kind of hard to see here
but we can zoom in
and you see okay we're doing a decent
job with the average
not terrible but also not much to write
home about
so if we're say looking five years out
here
this is about a
four log point increase
uh would be the estimated effect but
that's
kind of the same magnitude as we see
over here
for our
imbalance pre-treatment okay so you
wouldn't look at this and say like this
is definitely an effect here when this
is actually the same order as the
92 here
all right yeah
um so this is so you'll see in a second
why i wrote it this way but this is the
separate one and i've just written it
as a matrix gamma
collecting all the separate weights
together
but you're right you're getting the
optimization of the separator so in this
particular case yes this i mean you can
just mechanically you can do it jointly
but what you're actually doing i mean
it's equivalent to doing it separately
combining but
you're teeing up for me i wrote it this
way intentionally
right something we could we could fix
which is to say all right
this is
trying to minimize the imbalance
separately
and then averaging
well if we're interested in the average
maybe we should flip that right
so
let's move the norm outside let's take
the average first
and then try to minimize that average
and we'll call that thing the pooled
balance
and so when we do that
unsurprisingly we get something that's
right at zero
why well now we're trying to balance an
average and the average is in the middle
of this big
noisy thing and it's much easier to
balance something in the middle
um and so
i should say i think already this is
um
aren't you just basically evaluating
yourself on the training set i mean it's
one of the fundamental things in machine
learning of course you aimed for zero
you got zero on the free period
um uh yes absolutely and actually this
is um
uh this is teeing up what what comes
next which is we think that this
overshoots
um i should say in general this is a
hard problem in that it's hard for a lot
of reasons but one is we it's it's a
high dimensional problem and that we
have lots and lots of lagged outcomes
but we don't have a lot of data but we
only have 50 states and that's a pretty
canonical setting
so one of the challenges is sort of how
do you best take advantage of that data
structure
right um recognizing that indeed you
only have kind of a single training set
so i do think that's a problem yeah
could you instead say
if there
and i could see how well i could
recreate their post intervention
outcomes well let's say that 46 are
under control for 20
and i look at how well i could create
recreate the post-invention outcome so
that's like attached to error
so
absolutely
oh yeah sorry let me repeat the question
so the question is couldn't i use
couldn't i hold out some units and then
see how well this procedure does on
those units right so broadly in this
context there are two
two styles of hold out that people do
the first is what you just described
which is sometimes known as placebo in
space
right there different variations on the
theme but that's the basic idea is that
we hold out some things
in terms of units and then try to repeat
the procedure across units the other is
placebo and time which is can we
basically recode our data so that the
treatment indicator is say five years
earlier for everybody than it actually
is and then can we repeat
the procedure and see if we estimate a
zero
all right um in general i think the
placebo in time is a great approach
the problem with placebo in space
is that
we think that these units differ from
each other in important ways and so it's
hard there's no i
the iid-ness here is really quite
challenging and so with limited data
it's hard to kind of pull out a
reasonable hold outside at least in the
kinds of settings we're talking about
here if you have hundreds and hundreds
of units that's a little different but
with 50 states it's unclear how
in my opinion to do a good job of the
kind of this placebo in space it i think
it's just it's a harder it's a harder
problem
all right
um well good i'll get to talk about my
my first big idea and then we'll
i'm teeing up the other ones so
see we're doing a great job with this
pool then we're getting this
exactly to zero and then per the
question
uh coming from the voice of god
um
right maybe this overshoots a little bit
maybe we think we're over fitting to the
training set
and one way to characterize that is to
say well yeah we're getting better pool
balance but our state level imbalance is
worse
and our state level imbalance you can
see here this is the separate approach
versus the pooled approach everything is
kind of well above this line so we're
getting worse in balance for every state
and in the paper we sort of argue that
under some reasonable data generating
processes this matters not just if you
care about state-specific estimates but
also if you care about the average right
this essentially makes you less robust
to estimating a good average effect
and so our simple idea
is to just balance both
to change this optimization problem to
interpolate between these two things
and
here's the a sketch of that optimization
problem right now like this with a hyper
parameter nu
that basically gets us between these two
extremes
so if nu is zero
we focus entirely on the state level
balance and that puts us to the top left
corner here
right where we we don't care at all
about the pooled imbalance but we care
as much as possible about the average
state level imbalance
if we said new to one we're at this
other extreme here where we're trying
only to get good pooled imbalance we
care not at all about the separate
imbalance
and what do you see well
there's a frontier
and so we face a trade-off between these
two extremes
and in the paper we argue for some
heuristics as to where you might choose
but
one choice is like a half
and this is actually like a pretty
sensible place to be on this curve
um
even if you start here and you kind of
back off ever so slightly
right that also you also end up at a
pretty sensible place
on this curve
and so
we see here right this is you see we're
not again precisely zero on this measure
um but we're still pretty close
and we can also look at this this is a
univariate measure of state level
imbalance
we can see
this is if we do it separately this is
if we do the pooled
and then this is if we do that joint
partially
so i'm out of time but one thing to
mention is you'll notice
these two guys out here
are still annoyingly far away
from everybody else
and so our other paper
tries to get at all right what if
waiting alone
doesn't get you what you want
and we end up with a formula that will
look familiar to
causal inference folks everywhere
which is to say all right if we have
remaining imbalance
one thing we can do is we can bring in
an outcome model
right and that outcome model in our in
the paper we talk a lot about using just
linear regression with a ridge penalty
like a very simple outcome model
it actually turns out that even just
using
an intercept is the outcome model which
has been proposed by a few folks
is a really sensible thing to do in a
lot of cases
and so for example you would put in you
take out the inner the pre-treatment
intercept here
and then you use synthetic controls to
rewrite the residuals
so hence we would call it hence we call
the augmented synthetic control approach
and you can see that here for new york
here's new york kind of well above
the convex hall of the other states but
once we de-mean
now we're back in business
and so we get this is without the
demeaning this is with mean
so um
let me uh we can put it all together
right
and when we when we for example combine
partially pooling with this intercept
shift
what we end up doing is basically moving
our frontier down so we just get better
balance overall
you know at the cost of a little bit
more structure but we think in general
this approach
is really kind of a reasonable default
for a lot of these kinds of panel data
settings where you might use synthetic
controls
all right um skip over that the one
thing i want to end on before i
let everyone go to break
is this notion that synthetic controls
we can think of as part of this broader
class of balancing rights problems
and um
shout out to some of the folks in the
room like rahul right there's um
all the ideas we've talked about here
are direct analogs of things that folks
have done in this kind of
cross-sectional case with balancing
weights
so at a high level right the idea of
balancing weights
let's go back to the cross-sectional
data setting
where we our goal this is very stylized
right our goal is to estimate some
missing counter factual mean
and we have a propensity score right the
probability of treatment given
covariates
and so we all know the first propensity
score identity which is to say let's
reweight the control outcomes right this
is just att weights we rewrite the
control outcomes and on average they'll
give us this missing mean
a corollary to this that's um not always
is appreciated as much is that this is
also true for covariates as well as
outcomes so in expectation the
re-weighted covariates will have the
same distribution
as the target covariance
so this is true if we know the
propensity score
but in practice and observational
settings we need to estimate propensity
score and broadly there are two
approaches
the first approach which we all know and
love
is to try to get a propensity score
estimate that's close to the true
propensity score right to get pi hat
close to pi
and so how would you do that you would
use some maximum likelihood approach
like logistic regression or some machine
learning approach like logistic
regression
and
um you then get those estimates and you
plug them in here
and uh get weights so you directly
estimate the probability of treatment
you re-weigh units and then you try to
get covert balance
but the trouble is that in practice
if you have um even a moderate number of
covariates you often end up with
estimates that are close to zero and one
and so you can end up with extreme
weights right high variance and lousy
coverage balance
the idea behind balancing weights is to
flip the script
and to instead find weights
that are close to the true ipw weights
so you find weights directly by solving
a series of coverage balancing equations
usually
right
and then that's going to directly give
you balance and then indirectly give you
an estimated currency score
so this is a very old idea if you're a
surveys person you've seen this in
things like raking and survey
calibration but it seemed kind of a
renaissance in the causal inference
literature in the last few years
um
we have a recent review paper on it up
on archive
and
the point i want to make is this is what
a typical
balancing weights problem looks like
we have some squared some imbalance
measure like difference in coverage
means or something like that and our
goal is to find weights that minimize
some
squared imbalance measure
plus some penalty on the weights
with the constraint that the weights are
on the simplex
and so this is a pretty general setup a
lot of existing methods fit into this
framework but this should look familiar
synth is just a special case of this
thing
where we have where our imbalance
measure
is uh
the squared imbalance and the lagged
options
so
um
i will
spare you this but um i think that
connection to me thinking about synth as
a part of this broader class of problems
has been very helpful in trying to
understand when it works well and what
it does
so wrapping up
um you said standard sense requires
excellent pre-trimmed fit unclear what
to do without it
we have two papers that try to
combine across multiple units and also
to combine with outcome modeling
uh this is all important in the great
part package augs thanks to
eli ben michael i contributed basically
nothing
um
and so we uh
we're
we're kind of pushing on this
uh in a bunch of different directions so
with some folks here we're looking at
what happens in multiple outcomes series
how to do things like sensitivity
analysis we also have a paper up that
does uh
a bayesian formulation of this problem
that i actually really like totally
different way of tackling it but to me i
think it helps get at some of the deeper
issues and then i think lastly is just a
call to say that this this literature on
panel data methods has been exploding on
the um on the kind of stats method side
but there's a big gap between what folks
are doing in practice and so one of the
things that i'm hoping to do with
various teams of people is to try to get
some of these methods more usable uh and
in lots of situations that apply
researchers face
um
one last plug
i'm shameless but if you're in this room
you care about causal inference and
you're already like berkeley so the
american causal influence conference is
here at uc berkeley may 23rd 25th
website here sign up we already have 200
and almost 250 people registered so it's
going to be a great time so please come
and yes thank you
[Applause]
we'll go on a break and keep the
questions for the panel awesome